أنت ذاهب إلى منزل جدتك وأنت
جالس في مقعدك في العشرين من عمره ، انظر إلى الرجل في العشرين
من العمر وهو يعطس ثم يسعل ، ثم
تدرك أنه قد يكون مصابًا بنزلة برد أو أسوأ
من الأنفلونزا ، فكيف تأخذ هذه
الرحلة بالطائرة دون أن تصل إلى
وجهتك مع سيلان الأنف بنفسك
د.  تقول أماندا فيلازكويز إن
علاجك يجب أن يبدأ قبل أن تبدأ
الرحلة ،
لذا حاول الحفاظ على نظام غذائي متوازن
وممارسة الرياضة بانتظام
والحفاظ على روتين نومك حتى يكون
جسمك في أفضل حالاته قبل
السفر ونسيان إهدار المال
على فيتامين سي  مكملات د.
يقول فيلازكويز إنه لا يوجد دليل على أن تناول
فيتامين سي الإضافي سيعزز نظام المناعة لديك ،
لذا فإن أفضل شيء يمكنك فعله بصدق
هو اتباع نظام غذائي متوازن يحتوي على الكثير
من الأطعمة الغنية بمضادات الأكسدة مثل
الفواكه والخضروات وأن تكون قادرًا على التأكد من تناولها.
الكثير من
النوم ، كما توصي بلقاح الإنفلونزا في
حالة تعرضك لشخص
مصاب بالأنفلونزا ولا تظهر عليه أي علامات عليه
ولا تخشى ارتداء قناع لتغطية
فمك وأنفك ، فهذه طريقة جيدة
لديك حاجز بينك وبين
الآخرين الذين قد يعرضونك
للسعال أو العطس ، وإذا
كنت مريضًا ، فافعل للجميع معروفًا
ولا تأخذ الرحلة ، فهذا هو الوقت
المناسب لتطبيق بند تأمين السفر الخاص بك
الذي يسمح  يمكنك إلغاء
تذكرة السفر واسترداد أموالك إذا
مرضت قبل رحلتك في
الدقيقة الصحية لليوم ، أنا ريك أتلف إليلا